are you sure this isn't you yeah man I'm
pretty sure I wasn't a death-row lawyer
who collected clown paintings and
rescued orphans they got my name ripe
and nothing else I mean somebody royally
[ __ ] up
somebody forked up why can't I say Fork
if you're trying to curse you can't hear
I guess a lot of people in this
neighborhood don't like it so it's
prohibited it's full shirt hey Janet how
can I help you what the for could come
on I'm just asking you to fudge a little
bit you must have told a few white lies
in your life I mean what was your job I
was a professor of ethics in moral
philosophy and I would just like to
quickly say if any of you would like to
play tennis tonight we have 36
regulation grass tennis courts fun
[Applause]
[Music]
oh honey is real but huh hey at least I
can still say Butthead Eleanor this is
all happening because of you
I'm sorry Eleanor but there's nothing
anyone can do unless there is something
we can do unless you could teach me
teach you what how to be good that was
your job right a professor of ethics
no one knew I was a problem when I
arrived things only started getting
crazy after I was an [ __ ] to everyone
at the party
ah you know I'm trying to say ash hole
and not ash hole right I got that yes
have fun
nerds I'll be soaring through the air
like a fork and herb hop on the launch
pad and conjure an image that brings you
pure joy some people think of their
wedding day or favorite vacation spot
people puking on rollercoasters people
puking on rollercoasters hey I got you a
present
what synagogue that's not the president
that's just common decency yeah but I
fork and nailed it shirt well then this
plant is doomed because tomorrow I'm
going with her and I'm gonna prove to
you and to everyone that she is secretly
a two-faced calculating phony bench yeah
truth hurts doesn't it plants hmm Oh
fork that's been you sent me these
threatening notes what the fork man when
I say I'm meditating I'm just trying to
figure out what the fork is happening we
need a distraction right the fork now
you didn't get into heaven at all shirt
for brains and I can finally relax it's
for him perfect no and all three of us
are royally [ __ ] thoughts I just want
to say once more for the record that
this whole good bad system is [ __ ]
dude what the fork here's the bedroom
it's kind of hard to get up on this dumb
ledge though like you have got to be
[ __ ] kidding me
but we are not giving up I believe that
Eleanor belongs in the good place if I'm
wrong you can take her to the bad place
and punish her all you want just really
go to town but she's staying here now
all of you get the fork out of my
neighborhood every time the simple fact
of my existence starts to bum you out I
want you to hold this up
and and surprisingly jacked and Oh for
chyme in love with Cheney you and I have
a weird complicated forked up friendship
but it's our friendship
hey I'm really sorry that I didn't tell
you about John you and that you got
saddled with him yes that is regrettable
but I forgive you
maybe you two is soul mates
holy shirt maybe we are
this is pointless the ticker isn't even
going up and everyone's giving me the
stink-eye
heyno everyone hates you before q2 gonna
turn up to novice you have threw nothing
party Wow thanks but it's not working
not one more point fork
Oh shirt I know what I have to do
is a smokin hot turd
Holy Mother for King shirt boss what Wow
no this doesn't make any sense this is
paradise oh it looks like paradise but
it's actually a filthy dumpster full of
our worst anxieties I'm surrounded by
people who are literally better than me
just me being here forced cheating into
an ethical cluster fork you hurt
everyone in your life with your rigidity
and your indecisiveness Oh Fork
hi there who are you
I'm Janet I think this is yours after I
was rebooted I found it in my mouth what
what the fork is at Gd why can't I say
Fork
got you a little something to wear here
and now all the top point getters wear
these on the first night oh you gotta be
fortunate you already forgot her name
no I didn't her name is Janet and imap4
cough okay some shrimp in one of my many
many Kaka
Pop's pockets the fork is happily quite
confused let me explain
gorgeous I don't know what this place is
but it is certainly not the good place
Michael is forking with us also
apparently sashes are out this season
the diagonal line really draws ones eye
to the chin blood go for yourself you
mean giraffe Oh working shirt clam
chowder is disgusting it's just hot
ocean milk with dead animal croutons
human meeting bedroom now oh yeah that
hole no stair thing that was part of the
torture let me go
son of a bench Michael is a liar I think
there's a 99% chance he's forking with
us her an immortal being he's pretty
fragile I mean the guy contemplates his
own death for one forking minute and
completely loses his grip on reality
let's try the doctor one dude what the
fork no no not all good you keep saying
that we need you or we'll end up getting
tortured forever but then when we do
help you out we still end up getting
tortured I'd rather just be tortured
then choose it you are no longer welcome
in my class get the fork out girl you
are a messy bench who loves drama and I
am into it I'll go somewhere else
fine no not fine don't go somewhere else
okay
yeah we're forked here aren't we Wow
you you really did just come here to
chat didn't you just shoot the shirt
with your old pal Eleanor I guess oh
yeah why
coming up next grandma got run over by a
reindeer
we're going straight
but one time I think someone isn't lying
to me and it bites me in the ash okay I
don't know about you guys but I say we
leave this miserable shirt hole I don't
know about you guys but I am definitely
the best version of myself I know a
shirt ton about ethics no son of a [ __ ]
still happy I can swear now but
everything else about this is very bad
we're gonna start with a simple
three-second memory why only three
seconds Ohio and or well Joe I don't
know Eleanor morning mama dawn morning
Vicki was two are such for King dweebs
are you I have one more little surprise
for you okay open them
oh the fork fork what do you think
throw some [ __ ]
what are you talking about no forking
way we're not rebooting where are we
we're in the good place no offense dude
but you have told us a lot of Lies in
the last 300 years so seriously where
the fork are we fork shirt [ __ ] holy
for King shirt balls
[Music]
you